QUORUM YET FOR THE JANUARY
ELEVENTH. TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
INSURANCE COMMITTEE HEARING. IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY. WE ONE
BILL ON THE AGENDA IT IS- AB
THREE NINE NINE BY MISTER SALAS
. ANNA MISTER GRAYSON WHO IS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL BE
PRESENTING THAT BILL. WE WON'T
VOTE OBVIOUSLY UNTIL WE HAVE A
QUORUM. BUT LET'S GO AHEAD. AND
GET UNDER WAY. GO AHEAD MR
GRAYSON THANK YOU MITER CHAIR
CHAIR A CHAIR DALY CHERRY
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB THREE NINE NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS. IT DOES
ALLOW AN INJURED EMPLOYEE TO
REQUEST THE MEDICAL PROVIDER
NETWORK WHICH IS M. P. N. NAME
AND IDENTIFICATION NUMBER FROM
THEIR EMPLOYER IN INSTANCES
WHERE THE EMPLOYER OBJECTS TO AN
INJURED EMPLOYEES SELECTION OF A
POSITION ON THE GROUNDS. THAT
THE POSITION IS NOT WITHIN THE
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK USED BY
THE EMPLOYER. LAMES
ADMINISTRATORS CAN UTILIZE
THOUSANDS OF INDIANS WITH MOST
IDENTIFIED BY NAME ONLY WHICH
OFTENTIMES LOOK AND SOUND
IDENTICAL. FOR AN INJURED WORKER
THERE IS NO EASY WAY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER A SELECTED
POSITION FALLS WITHIN A
PARTICULAR MPN IF THIS
INFORMATION IS NOT READILY
AVAILABLE THIS ALONE MAKES IT
DIFFICULT FOR AN INJURED WORKER.
TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT WITH A
DOCTOR WITHIN THE PROPER MPN
WHICH CAN RESULT IN DELAYS TO
ACCESSING CRITICAL TREATMENT.
THIS MEASURE WILL ALLOW INJURED
WORKERS TO IDENTIFY A NETWORK
POSITION AND IN THOSE INSTANCES
WHERE AN EMPLOYER WITHHOLDS THIS
INFORMATION PROVIDES FOR THE
BASIS OF AN INJURED WORKER TO BE
TREATED. OUTSIDE OF THE MEDICAL
PROVIDER NETWORK THIS
COMMONSENSE FIX WILL PROVIDE
INJURED WORKERS AND PHYSICIANS
WITH ACCESS TO CRITICAL
INFORMATION SUCH AS THE MEDICAL
PROVIDER NAME AND IDENTIFICATION
NUMBER. TESTIFYING VIA TELEPHONE
LINES IS DR JACOB ROSENBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF INDUSTRIAL MEDICINE AND
SURGERY. THIS BILL DOES HAVE NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS BEEN
NEGOTIATED AMONG STAKEHOLDERS
MISTER BRIDGEMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE PRESENTATION. WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE ROLE NOW TO
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM. GO AHEAD
TIFFANY. DALY HERE DALY HERE
MAYES BERMAN MATT SMITH HERE
CALDERON CALDERON HERE CERVANTES
FRONT IS HERE CHEN COOLEY.
COOLEY HERE COOPER GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON HERE RODRIGUEZ
RODRIGUEZ HERE VOEPEL WOULD
WOULD HERE. GOOD WE HAVE A
QUORUM. AND LET ME NOTE ALSO FOR
THE RECORD THAT- THE WARD BILL.
HAS BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
- AB NINE NINE ONE HAS BEEN
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR- GO AHEAD
THE MISTER GRAYSON YOU WERE
ABOUT TO A YOU NOTED THAT
SOMEONE WAS GOING TO BE
TESTIFYING TO WHAT THE IPHONE
AFTER JACOB ROSENBERG ON THE
LINE CALIFORNIA GOOD GOOD.
UNLIMITED JUMP INTO THE
PARTICIPATION. PROTOCOLS MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN PARTICIPATE IN
THE HEARING TODAY BY CALLING.
877-692-8957 THE PASSCODE OF.
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR- FOR MEMBERS MAY
PARTICIPATE IN PERSON. SO LET'S
GO LET'S SEE OF FOR MR.
ROSENBERG MISTER ROSENBERG OF
ROSENBERG DR ROSENBERG LET'S SEE
IF HE'S ON THE LINE. HELLO GOOD
GO AHEAD SIR I AM ON THE LINE GO
AHEAD THANK YOU. IT I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO THIS
IS A VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL
IT'S JUST GOING TO HELP-
POSITIONS DETERMINE WHETHER
THEY'RE THE RIGHT POSITION TO-
TREATING INJURED WORKER WHETHER
WE'RE IN THE MEDICAL PROVIDER
NETWORK AND IF WE'RE NOT IN THE-
RIGHT MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK.
TO HELP GET THEM TO- TO
PROVIDERS THE THAT IS IN THE
MEDICAL PROVIDER NETWORK- RIGHT
NOW THERE'S A THERE'S A BRIGHTER
PROBLEMS THAT OCCUR IF- IF. THE
PATIENT CHOOSES THE POSITION IS
OUTSIDE THE MPN- BUT- MAJOR
ISSUES THE TREATMENT GETS
DELAYED AND THAT OF COURSE MEANS
THAT PEOPLE DON'T GET BACK TO
WORK. AND THAT'S QUITE
PROBLEMATIC- DELAYING TREATMENT
SOMETIMES RESULTS IN MORE OF A
SIGNIFICANT INJURIES AND SO IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT THEY WIND UP
WITH THE RIGHT POSITION RIGHT
AWAY. SADLY IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO TRACK DOWN THE FIRST PACIFIC
MPM THAT THE WORKERS IN- A LOT
OF INSURANCE COMPANIES OF
MULTIPLE MTN'S- WITH SIMILAR
SOUNDING NAMES. THAT YOU THINK
THAT POSITION WOULD KNOW EVERY
EMPTY AND THAT THEIR END BUT IT
TURNS OUT THAT WE- WE HAVE A
HARD TIME IDENTIFYING THE
DIFFERENT MPN SYNCING WHICH ONCE
RAN AS WELL. SO THIS WOMAN SOME
CLARITY TO A SITUATION AND HELP
THE INJURED WORKERS GET THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED TO GET
BACK TO WORK MORE QUICKLY. WE
NEGOTIATED VERY CAREFULLY- WITH
THE PAYERS BUT WE DIDN'T WANT TO
PUT ANY UNDUE BURDEN ON THEM AND
THEY WERE SATISFIED WITH THAT
THIS BILL WAS WORTH. THANK YOU
THANK YOU DOCTOR ROSENBERG. OF
MISTER GRAYSON OTHER IN OTHER
WITNESSES THAT YOU HAVE LINED UP
I DO NOT HAVE ANY LISTED THANK
YOU SIR ALL RIGHT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER PERSONS WHO ARE WHO WANT
TO PARTICIPATE VIA PHONE. OR IN
PERSON. ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL. ANY
TESTIMONY AGAINST THIS BILL.
WELCOME MISTER COOPER WHERE THIS
BILL. AND I WANT TO WELCOME A
MEMBER SABRINA CERVANTES TO OUR
INSURANCE COMMITTEE GOOD TO SEE
HERE. AND THANK MR SMITH FOR
PINCH HITTING FOR. MR BIGELOW
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU-
ANY QUESTIONS OF MR GRAYSON ON
THIS SALAS BILL MANY QUESTIONS.
ALRIGHT IF NOT ALL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. DO I THINK THERE'S A
MOTION AND SECOND TO APPROVE AB
THREE NINE NINE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- LET'S GO AHEAD AND
VOTE. DALY HI DALY I MAYES
BERMAN SMITH SMITH I CALDERON
CALDERON AYE CERVANTES TORONTO'S
I CHEN COOLEY COOLEY AYE COOPER.
COOPER I GIPSON GRAYSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE RODRIGUEZ RODRIGUEZ
I VOEPEL WOULD. WOOD I. LOOKS
LIKE NOT NINE YES VOTES NO OTHER
VOTES CAST NINE ZERO ALL RIGHT
ANYTHING ELSE FOR THE GOOD OF
THE ORDER TODAY THE COMPLETES
OUR AGENDA. ALL RIGHT. I WON'T
CLOSE THE HEARING YET BECAUSE A
COUPLE MEMBERS ARE ON THEIR WAY
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH. NICE
JOB MISTER GRAYSON. YOU SEE IT
OKAY. YES. I'M.
SO FOR THE
RECORD WILL NOTE TO MR BERMAN
AND MR GIBSON. ARE NOW IN
ATTENDANCE AT THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE HEARING. WE HAVE A
VOTED ALREADY ON SALAS IS BILL
AB THREE NINE NINE IT'S A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION. TO
APPROPRIATIONS- GO AHEAD TIFFANY
I BERMAN BERMAN I. GET IT SORRY
IF THAT. THANK YOU GENTLEMEN FOR
MAKING OUR HEARING PRECIADO IT'S
A BUSY DAY. ALL RIGHT GOOD LUCK
THANK YOU SO. SALAS IS BILL IS
NOW ELEVEN TO ZERO. MANAGE TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS. ALL
RIGHT I THINK THAT CONCLUDES
RIGHT. THE HEARING IS CONCLUDED
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH.